hey John
I guess you've heard by now auto power
off by the still some glitches to work
out hello John by now you have received
my message that we will no longer be
communicating through any textual means
no more instant messaging no more
emailing only video blogging and
possibly phone calls you can see my eye
in my eye okay just try to ignore that
there you can't see it now can you last
night I sent you an email from a New
Year's Eve party in Lake Tahoe the email
outlined our plans starting on January
1st today I will send you a video blog
tomorrow you will reply to that finish
line we will continue like this until
the year is up
if one of us fails to send a video blog
on a weekday there will be certain
punishments the punishments will be
outlined later I finished this email
cross my heart hope to die and I may
very possibly be required to stick a
needle in my eye that's the kind of
punishment I'm talking about Brotherhood
2.0 convinces today
does that make us crazy probably
ah